i'm darren schmitz with vmware
in this third video of the series i will
show configuring the site pair mappings
in advanced settings within site
recovery manager
site pair mappings are important within
site recovery manager because they
establish the one-to-one relationships
of the different resources between both
sites
let's get started by clicking view
details for the site pair that was
configured in the last video
from this screen all the resource
mappings that can be configured are
arranged along the left-hand column
working our way top to bottom the
replication servers section shows which
vsphere replication servers are in use
at both sites by clicking on each
vcenter instance
since we are not using array-based
replication these options can be
collapsed as we move on to the network
mapping section
once there clicking on the new button
launches the wizard to define the
network mappings
the creation mode allows resources with
matching names to be automatically
paired however due to some of the
built-in networks being unneeded manual
mode will suffice for the network
mapping section
expanding the distributed virtual
switches reveals all the networks for
both sites
the key to this exercise is matching
one-for-one networks both on site one
and site two
while most of the built-in networks like
the edge networks and hcx networks are
probably not necessary an admin could
add them if needed
that all said the two custom created
networks required in this environment
are the management network and the
workload network
with all of our equivalent networks
defined clicking next continues to the
reverse mapping screen
reverse mappings are used by the
reprotect mechanism for a workflow to
flow in the opposite direction
in this example the reverse mappings are
the mapping definitions from site 2 back
to site 1. by default when testing a
recovery plan srm will auto create
isolated networks however admins do have
the option to click change and specify
any network desired
an additional feature with each network
mapping is ip customization
this will customize each virtual
machine's ip settings as they move
between sites
for example if a virtual machine is
assigned ip 33.20 at site 1 it will be
given 53.20 at site 2.
however since the demo virtual machines
are using dhcp i will just cancel
folder mappings are next much like the
other resource categories the equivalent
folders are added the reverse mappings
are selected and the category is
completed
resource mappings define the equivalent
resource groups in the cluster
so if you have specific groups for
production test or development
they can all be added to ensure balanced
application performance levels when the
virtual machines are started at the
other site
storage policies must also have mappings
due to the large number of built-in
policies setting the creation mode to
automatically prepare mappings
potentially saves multiple clicks
in this case all 12 policies are
automatically matched and added
within the placeholder data store
section the vsan data stores for each
site have already been automatically
added
finally there are the advanced settings
while the defaults are typically
recommended when first getting started
these settings may need to be adjusted
as the environment scales
the settings for large site recovery
manager environments can be found in the
vmware online documentation
now that all the environments
prerequisite setup items are complete
check out the next video in the series
to learn how to configure replications
protection groups and recovery plans for
an application
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
[Music]